let's try instead manuel from florida
welcome
hey um
nice to speak with you likewise florida
is doing doing just fine is that right
yeah it feels like i'm walking out into
an oven whenever i leave my house though
so it's pretty hot down here well at
least the house isn't so hot
yeah no that's true the bills are pretty
high because of that but i bet yeah we
have to take it i'm curious what's like
your what's your like
top electrical bill in the summer
so i have this like 1 500 square foot
house and in the summer it could get to
250 dollars
oh i have to tell you that's not that
bad and you keep you're running the ac
almost 24 7 i assume
oh yeah okay that's actually not that
shocking that's that's all right well
fair i thought you were going to tell me
800 or something
oh wow i didn't know
electricity was that expensive in other
places i i think there are places where
if you run the ac all every day you can
get some crazy bills yeah but good
you're not that's a problem you're not
dealing with at least
yes yeah yes
um but yeah i did wanted to ask you this
question so i was speaking with somebody
uh about
you know this contentious topic of
abortion rights and whatnot yes and you
know the the topic tends to revolve
around
when life begins and stuff and i've
heard people say
that
it's science can't tell us when it
begins i've heard people say
science can't even tell us
when it ends
and i just get kind of concerned and i
wonder is it practical for us to
to make such definitions or should we
look at life and death
like a in in a nuanced way and
like uh yeah well i don't actually think
i don't think the solution
is everybody agrees to look at when life
begins in a nuanced way i think what the
issue is that
even if we got some answer as to when
life begins it still isn't going to
change anyone's mind if they're against
abortion for religious reasons
if imagine that science said hey you
know what
and and by the way
the real issue is when are we talking
about a person not when life begins i
mean no one would deny that a clump of
cells is a form of life the relevant
question is are we talking about a
person and if it's a person does it get
due process does it get citizenship does
it get child support can you get the
child tax credit when you're pregnant
you know all these other things that
that are really about personhood rather
than life but imagine that science said
hey
life begins at nine weeks and six days
into the gestational period
do we then all agree about abortion i
mean it just it in that sense it's a red
herring you know what i mean
yeah 100
and whenever i do talk about this i do
like to frame it in the the personhood
kind of way right because
i mean science is ever changing and and
who knows right like
we may
understand that a nine-week old fetus
has a full conscious right but at the
end of the day we assign personhood
um and we value
like
the choice of the woman in her life and
her safety
in these ways right regardless of
of that but yeah personhood is great but
i just get
i get worried because it kind of makes
pro-choice
sound crazy when people
say things like well we actually never
know
like it's impossible to know and it's
also impossible to know
like
when people die like and then it just
makes things feel relative and i know i
kind of
i get lost in that yeah yeah i mean i
think there's some value to to the speed
limit analogy which is like listen
sometimes to live in a society
we have to draw lines where there are
gray areas so
you probably would have
imagine a road where you go listen 100
miles an hour no one's going to say 100
miles an hour is a reasonable speed
limit here and no one's going to say
that it's 5. we're going to set the
speed limit at 40
and certainly if it's dry and clear you
could probably safely go 55 if it's dark
and icy you're going to have to go
slower but this is where we're kind of
drawing the line and when we get into
these rare circumstances of like partial
birth abortions as they're sometimes
called late-term abortions everybody has
a term that's loaded that they want to
apply to it and then they say well uh
it's it it's we're talking about a
person at seven months and someone goes
well here's one way where it would
really be six and here's another way it
the from the standpoint of policy
sometimes lines have to be drawn when
things are blurry but this is a
different question then if we got an
answer to when life begins then do we
resolve the debate the answer is
obviously no
yeah 100 well thanks a ton for your time
and thank you for the call i appreciate
it all right there's manuel from florida
my audience knows i read i read a ton of
books i read nonfiction i read fiction
at night i'm always trying to consume
information and the truth is i don't
have the time to read every non-fiction
book that i would like to read one thing
i do not have time to add to what i'm
reading in paper form is more history
but i want to know about history and
that's where our sponsor blinkist comes
in blinkist doesn't replace reading
books cover to cover the way i love to
do but for example with everything going
on right now with roe v wade i wanted
more of a detailed history of roe v wade
in the united states so on blinkist i
was able to get a 15-minute condensed
audiobook of the mary ziegler book
abortion and the law in america roe v
wade to the present and in 15 minutes i
get a great overview blinkist also has
slide presentations that will take you
about 15 minutes to go through so
it's not to replace reading it's in
addition to for me you get the key
takeaways from blinkist from the books i
would certainly otherwise miss out on
you can try blinkist for free for seven
days and get a 25 discount off of a
subscription at
blinkist.com pacman the link is down
below